>> Tucker: LESS THAN 10 MILES
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE, A MIDDLE
SCHOOL IS BEING TERRORIZED BY
MS-13.
IT'S CALLED A WILLIAM WORK
MIDDLE SCHOOL IN MARYLAND.
IT'S ONE OF MANY THAT HAS HAD A
MASS SETTLEMENT OF UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS ENTERING THE COUNTRY FROM
LATIN AMERICA.
ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST," MS-13
MEMBERS IN THE SCHOOL START
FIGHTS, SELL DRUGS AND ASSAULT
FELLOW STUDENTS.
TEACHERS SAY THEY FEAR BEING
ALONE WITH SOME OF THESE KIDS
AND ALSO FEARS SAYING ANYTHING
ABOUT IT BECAUSE SPEAKING OUT
COULD COST THEM THEIR JOBS.
THE TRAGEDY CAN ALMOST BE TRACED
ENTIRELY TO THE IMMIGRATION
POLICY BUT, MOST CRUSHED THE
CONVERSATION BY SCREAMING
"RACIST."
JOSE RIST A WRIST IS FORMER DNC
PRESS SECRETARY.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
WHAT I FOUND IRONIC ABOUT THE
STORY WAS, THIS IS THE THIRD
ITERATION OF THE MS-13 STORY.
FIRST WE WERE TOLD IT WAS A
FIGMENT OF THEIR IMAGINATION.
THEN WE WERE TOLD TO ATTACK THEM
AND CALL THEM NAMES IS IMMORAL.
AND THEN ARE WE ALLOWED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THEY ARE TERRORIZING
THE STUDENTS OR ARE WE BIGOTS
FOR DOING SO?
>> IF YOU ARE UNDOCUMENTED IN
THIS COUNTRY, IF YOU ARE A
CRIMINAL INCLUDING BEING A
MEMBER OF MS-13, WE DON'T WANT
YOU IN THIS COUNTRY AND YOU
SHOULD BE DEPORTED.
PART OF THE ISSUE HERE IS PEOPLE
LIKE YOURSELF AND SOME
REPUBLICANS WANT TO PINPOINT AND
SIMPLY SAY, BECAUSE YOUR FIRST
NAME IS JOSE, OR YOU ARE LATINO,
LIKE ME, YOU ARE AUTOMATICALLY
AND MS-13 GANG MEMBER.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE A
RIDICULOUS PERSON FOR SAYING
THAT, I HAVE NEVER SUGGESTED
ANYTHING LIKE THAT AND IT'S
APPALLING THAT YOU SHOULD SAY
THAT.
YOU ARE SPEAKING A LIE, AND NOT
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
WHAT I SAID WAS WHAT I READ IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WHICH IS
SELF IDENTIFIED MEMBERS ARE
DESTROYING THE SCHOOL.
I BET YOU NEVER SEND YOUR KIDS
TO THAT SCHOOL.
BUT YOU HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
THOSE PEOPLE BEING IN THIS
COUNTRY BECAUSE IT FITS IN THAT
DEMOGRAPHIC THAT YOU APPROVE OF.
THE TRUTH IS, IT'S A DISASTER.
>> IF YOU ARE AND MS-13 GANG
MEMBER AND YOU ARE UNDOCUMENTED,
YOU SHOULD BE DEPORTED.
>> Tucker: THEN WHY HAVE YOU
CONSISTENTLY ATTACKED ANYBODY --
YEAH RIGHT, NOBODY HAS SAID THAT
THE MAJORITY OF IMMIGRANTS ARE
CRIMINALS OR BAD, I DON'T SAY
THAT AND I DON'T THINK IT.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID THAT.
>> Tucker: HE HAS NOT SAID
THAT.
YOU ARE LYING FOR POLITICAL GAIN
AS ALWAYS.
WHAT I HAVE SAID IS THAT WE
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE
PEOPLE COMING IN.
THERE ARE 20 MILLION OF THEM
LIVING HERE, WE DON'T KNOW THE
BACKGROUND, AND SOME OF THEM ARE
BAD PEOPLE.
>> WOULD PASS COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM, WE LEGALIZE
IT THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE AND IT
WILL BE A WHOLE LOT EASIER,
TUCKER, TO LOOK FOR THE REAL
CRIMINALS AFTER WE LEGALIZE THE
GOOD ONES, DON'T YOU THINK SO?
>> Tucker: IT'S HILARIOUS THAT
THAT SOLUTION COMPORTS EXACTLY
YOUR POLITICAL GOAL.
>> GIVE ME A BREAK.
>> Tucker: YOU TELL ME
RATIONALLY, HOW, IF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, THE INABILITY OF
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT TO SHOW WHO
IS LIVING WITHIN ITS BORDERS IS
THE PROBLEM, HOW ENCOURAGING
MORE OF IT WHICH IS WHAT AMNESTY
WOULD DO IS THE SOLUTION?
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THEY ARE
INTERESTED IN SOLVING.
>> SO YOUR ANSWER AND MANY
REPUBLICANS ANSWER IS TO DEPORT
THE IMMIGRANTS IN THE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: WE ARE GUESSING AT
THAT NUMBER.
SOME PEOPLE THINK IT'S
20 MILLION.
>> OKAY, 20 MILLION DEPORTED.
>> Tucker: WHEN WAGE GROWTH
HAS BEEN STAGNANT AND THE COST
OF EVERYTHING IS GROWING MUCH
FASTER THAN THE WAGES, YOU NEED
TO STOP THE ABILITIES OF
EMPLOYERS TO HIRE CHEAPER PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY ARE HERE ILLEGALLY.
>> WE CAN'T AFFORD TO KEEP THEM
HERE.
>> Tucker: IF YOU TOOK THIS
SERIOUSLY, AND YOU WERE BIGGER
THAN THE POLITICAL ISSUE -- >> I
AM TELLING YOU, WE HAVE A CHOICE
TO MAKE.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW NOTHING
ABOUT IT.
>> I KNOW MORE THAN YOU.
>> Tucker: WHY WOULD AN
EMPLOYER IN THIS COUNTRY BE
ALLOWED TO HIRE SOMEONE
ILLEGALLY, DEPRESSING WAGES FOR
AMERICAN CITIZENS?
>> YOU WANT TO FIX THAT PROBLEM?
REFORM THE SYSTEM AND LEGALIZE
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ALREADY
HERE.
>> Tucker: YOU COULD DO IT
TOMORROW.
WHY SHOULD EMPLOYERS BE ALLOWED
TO HIRE ILLEGAL ALIENS?
TELL ME WHY THEY SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO DO THAT.
>> WE HAVE TWO CHOICES.
THE POINT OF 14 MILLION OR
20 MILLION OR WHATEVER THE
NUMBER OR WE LEGALIZE THEM AND
GET THEM INTO THE SYSTEM SO WE
CAN GET THEM OUT OF THE SHADOWS.
>> Tucker: I DON'T HAVE TIME
FOR CONVERSATIONS WITH PEOPLE
WHO DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT AND HAVEN'T
THOUGHT IT THROUGH AND WANT TO
COME ON AND SPEW MORE TALKING
POINTS AND CALL ANYONE WHO